police fire tear gas to clear hundreds
trying to force their way into the
parliament building in the capital
kinshasa
[Applause]
they are supporters of president felix
tsushiketi
infuriated by what they see as a
judicial power grab in parliament
his party the union for democracy and
social progress
says the proposals would muzzle the
judiciary
and undermined the independence of
judges
a ploy they say to protect the party of
former president
joseph kabila as
hundreds surround parliament others set
fire to property zoned by kabila and his
associates
this law reform is very dangerous to our
justice system we are here to express
our opposition
we didn't vote for mps so they would
support such reforms in parliament
if passed judges would be under the
jurisdiction of the justice minister
a position held by the opposition party
of former president joseph kabila
the common front for congo or fcc it
also holds a majority in parliament
and government
parliament is blocking the development
of this country we say
no to this law it would create trouble
in our justice system
the former ruling coalition must be
aware that we
are the voters and we have power
kabila supporters say their proposals
are meant to fight corruption
by defining the oversight powers of the
justice ministry
fcc chief noemi walana issued a warning
to protesters
[Music]
careful protesters must realize that
everyone knows how it starts
but not how it ends
congolese politicians have been seen by
many as untouchable
a perception that appears to be changing
on saturday the president's own chief of
staff
vital kamari was sentenced to 20 years
of hard labor for stealing public money
he is the highest official
ever convicted of corruption in the drc
the conviction has earned praise for the
president and the courts
but there's clearly disagreement about
how independent
the courts should be kaziella pissodoyan
al jazeera